what other thing having to do with  Poland though Poland is a country great  people we have a lot of Polish Americans  living in the United States I've just  signed I will soon be dining and sign  certain preliminary applications we will  be giving a full visa waiver to Poland  that means that people from Poland can  easily travel there and people from here  can easily go back and forth they can  each people from the US people from  Poland can very easily go back and forth  between the United States and Poland  though they've been trying to get this  for many many decades and I got it for  the Polish people in honor of the Polish  people in the United States engine  calling so we're very happy with that